[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est palaleo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux on commence les palaleéo news
du mois d'octobre 2023 avec le projet
trinax le projet trinax qui a touché à
sa fin tout récemment vous voyez ici
notre photo traditionnelle sur la limite
Permien Trias donc le Trias il est ici
le Permien il est là le Permien étant
symbolisé par les espèces éteintes que
je représente et que Fiona représente
c'est Valentine qui prenit la photo donc
c'est Fiona qui a tenu la place pour
science de comptoir vous voyez sur cette
photo nos étudiants ils sont tous ravis
d'avoir pu participer à ce à ces
fouilles et tout ça c'est grâce à vous
grâce à votre soutien pour le projet
trinax vous voyez le le le le ranger de
la réserve vous voyez quelques élèves
plus jeunes qui sont les les élèves de
des des écoles locales dans le carou qui
nous ont rejoint pour pour ce jour de
fouille quand on était à oviston donc
voilà c'est grâce à vous merci encore on
a ramené une soixantaine de fossiles on
a surtout plus important on a ramené des
réponses à nos questions scientifiques
et ça c'est quand même le plus important
on a ramené des beaux souvenirs on a
ramené de l'expérience des points d'XP
pour nos étudiants qui maintenant ont
une expérience de terrain sur le carou
donc merci encore et donc pour en savoir
plus sur les les les futurs projets les
les futurs progrès pardon du projet
trinax et bien c'est la chaîne de
Valentine de sciences de comptoir qui il
faut suivre elle publiera ses vidéos
elle a de très très belles images très
belles photos de très très belles vidéos
donc voilà allez suivre science de
comptoir si vous voulez en apprendre
plus sur le projet trinax quand ces
vidéos sortiront on continue avec les
news d'Internet et la news du mois j'ai
envie de dire celle qui a fait le buzz
celle qui a celle qui a déclenché
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotions euh le
paléentologue le burger que vous
connaissez déjà si vous avez vu le
documentaire Netflix sur omomoaledi qui
est sorti récemment ou ma critique que
j'ai fait récemment sur ce documentaire
donc le paléontologue sud-africain le
burger a envoyé des fossiles dominidé
dans l'espace c'est la première fois
qu'on envoie des fossiles dominidés dans
l'espace à savoir une phalange d'un
homonaledi et une clavicule d'un
australopythecus sediba ceci étant dit
il y a deux squelettes et ce n'est pas
cette clavicule là qui a été envoyé mais
peu importe donc il y a une clavicule de
sdibaas et une fallange de mon ladyady
qui sont partis dans l'espace à
l'intérieur de cette petite capsules
voilà avec l'effigie du drapeau
sud-africain dessus qui sont partis donc
dans dans dans l'espace pour un petit
voyage he pas pour plusieurs heures hein
c'était juste un aller-retour rapide
dans la poche d'un milliardaire et ça ça
a fait le buzz et ça a surtout soulevé
beaucoup beaucoup d'indignation et très
honnêtement je me demande pourquoi alors
est-ce que c'était parce que c'était la
poche d'un milliardaire et que du coup
les milliardaires on les aime pas ou
bien est-ce que c'est cétait est-ce que
c'était comme le ce l'indiixe cet
article là un manque de justification à
savoir voilà il y a pas vraiment de
science derrière derrière tout ça mais
en même temps c'est évidemment juste
pour montrer que oui en Afrique du Sud
on a des fossiles et vous voyez on en a
tellement qu'on les envoie dans l'espace
voilà on peut se permettre de les
envoyer dans l'espace donc c'est c'est
évidemment une une communication stunt
une cascade de
communication de la part de liberger
mais
même s'il y a pas de science il y a pas
de raison scientifique d'envoyer ces
fossiles dans l'espace est-ce que ça
vaut le coup de s'indigner à ce point-là
parce que évidemment il y a tout un
paragraphe aussi sur quels sont les les
pour sur des gens qui se sont indignés
évidemment de de voir ces fossiles
partir dans l'espace de prendre de tels
risques pour ces fossiles alors très
honnêtement voilà vous avez le niveau 1
de la réaction qui est s'indigné bon ça
c'est le niveau que tout le monde a
c'est le niveau 1 de de la réaction
c'est vous vous indignez vous vous
faites un retweet en disant c'est une
honte et puis après on s'assoit 2
secondes et on réfléchit et très
honnêtement très honnêtement quand on
réfléchit à la justification
scientifique il y en a pas je suis
d'accord mais il y a pas plus de de
justification scientifique non plus dans
le fait d'envoyer un fossile à
l'étranger pour une exposition par
exemple c'est ça arrive tout le temps
avec les collections de qu'on a ici en
Afrique du Sud par exemple ça arrive
tout le temps et chaque voyage est un
risque et chaque voyage est pris sans
aucune justification scientifique c'est
pour une exposition il n'y aura pas de
science c'est juste pour une exposition
donc c'est juste pour de la
communication sauf que avec une
exposition vous allez toucher tout au
plus quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes grand maximum le burger avec
ça en envoyant des fossiles dans
l'espace il a touché des millions de
personnes il y a des millions de
personnes qui ont vu ça sur
internet donc mission
accomplie même pas j'allais dire point
d'interrogation mais en réalité il y a
pas point d'interrogation mission
accomplie euh donc oui le le but c'était
de faire de la communication c'était le
but avoué hein c'est ce qu'a dit euh
c'est ce qu'a dit euh la la l'agence
sud-africaine des ressources du
patrimoine donc le le ministre le
ministre de la Culture sud-africain a
mentionné que c'était euh c'était bel et
bien pour obtenir une reconnaissance
mondiale de la recherche sur les
origines humaines en Afrique du Sud et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est produit
donc quelle justification bah celle-là
c'est c'est de la communication au même
titre qu'une exposition dans un musée
serait de la communication excepté que
ça a été vachement plus
efficace voilà euh éducation beaucoup
moins mais très honnêtement combien de
fois vous êtes ressorti d'un musée en
ayant réellement appris quelque chose et
en ayant retenu quoi que ce soit c'est
pareil on on peut douter on peut se
poser les questions sur la réelle
efficacité d'une exposition dans un but
éducatif c'est c'est aussi quelque chose
qu'on peut remettre en question je ne
dis pas que ça sert à rien ne me faites
pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit mais on
peut douter de à quel point c'est
efficace là il y a il y a quelque chose
qui a été fait il y a quelque chose qui
a été produit il y a eu du chiffre ça a
marché c'est tout il y a eu buzz il y a
eu bad buzz mais il y a eu buzz mais un
bad buzz est un buzz
bref donc pour moi les justifications
même si elles ne sont pas scientifiques
elles sont pas non plus inadmissibles et
puis il y a les critiques qui ont été
formulées par d'autres scientifiques par
exemple donc le le manque de
justification scientifique du vol ça on
vient d'en parler mais surtout les
questions
éthiques parce que les les questions
éthiques bah surtout sur les dommages
qui auraient pu être fait au fossil
pendant le le vol mais comme j'ai dit
les fossiles africains qui prennent
l'avion la voiture le train le vélo pour
aller dans des exposition c'est tout le
temps et je suis désolé mais la voiture
c'était n'importe quel voyage en voiture
est beaucoup plus risqué qu'un voyage en
dans dans je sais pas quelle espèce de
shuttle ils utilisent pour aller dans
l'espace mais c'est largement plus
risqué c'est si on met des milliardaires
dedans c'est que globalement c'est pas
risqué hein ça va
euh et puis quel risque alors il y a eu
il y a eu l'émission enfin l'exposition
aux ultraviolets qui aurait pu détruire
les isotopes ou l'ADN les gars
sérieusement c'est c'est ça que vous
vous nous sortez quoi bon alors déjà il
y a eu des tests qui ont été faits et
non les fossiles ne sont pas revenus
radioactifs j'étais là quand ils ont été
faits donc non les fossiles ne sont pas
revenus radioactifs mais même même avant
ça à priori tous les fossiles de
australopythecus cedba sont ou presque
tous sont déjà passés dans un scanner à
rayon X sont déjà passés dans un et
pareil pour mononaledi d'ailleurs ils
sont déjà passés dans un scanner à x ils
sont déjà passés même dans un
synchrotron qui est un autre niveau de
puissance niveau rayonnement rayonnement
X et certains fossiles sont même passés
au scanner à neutron qui là pour le coup
a un est vraiment documenté comme
foutant en l'air les analyses
isotopiques donc je veux dire si ça
c'est si ça c'est valide pourquoi pas un
voyage dans l'espace de toute façon quoi
l'exposition au rayonnement au
rayonnement interstellaire enfin au
rayonnement stellaire dans l'espace
elle était pas dramatique c'était un vol
très très court et elle est pas elle est
pas plus grave en niveau conséquence que
ce qu'on fait généralement de ce qu'on
fait maintenant normalement subir au
fossiles quand on les découvre he parce
que passer les fossiles au rayon X
aujourd'hui c'est une démarche quasi
standard donc là là où je veux en venir
c'est que oui des risques des risques
liés à la manipulation des fossile il y
en a à chaque fois que vous manipulez un
fossile et donc donc les questions
éthiques je suis désolé mais elles sont
assez faciles les questions elles sont
vite répondues comme dirait l'autre euh
c'est oui il y a il y a des questions
éthiques que ça pose mais quand on
regarde bien ça pose pas des questions
éthiques si terribles que ça en réalité
et puis ça donne une fausse
représentation de la paléoanthropologie
mais alors ça si vous suivez la chaîne
vous
savez vous savez que de toute façon la
plupart pour ne pas dire la la quasi
totalité des efforts de communication à
propos de la
paléo-anthropologie de toute façon donne
une fausse représentation de la pratique
de la
paléoanthropologie toi-même tu sais euh
ça remet en question toute l'histoire de
l'humanité tout ça tout ça hein ce qui
est autrement plus nuisible à l'image
que les gens ont de la
paléoanthropologie que de les envoyer
dans l'espace hein balancer tous les 15
jours hein que que le moindre petit
rogâton de merde remet en question toute
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est autrement
plus nuisible donc bon pareil non je je
vois pas je vois pas et donc les gens
qui se sont exprimés en mode je suis
horrifié que qu'ils aient obtenu le
permis bah une fois tout ça encore une
fois une fois le côté horrifié
c'est-à-dire l'émotion m de côté quand
vous analysez froidement il s'est rien
passé il s'est rien passé d'exceptionnel
en réalité donc oui ça a été un un gros
buzz et ça a fait parler des fossiles et
donc c'est pas si grave que ça et et une
fois plus même si vous partez du
principe d'ailleurs je je reviens dessus
mais niveau question éthique même si
vous partez du principe que
la les rayonnements quoi que ce soit qui
se soit passé là-haut est totalement
détruit les possibilités de trouver de
l'ADN les possibilités de trouver des
isotopes les possibilités de dater les
fossiles ce qui n'est de toute façon pas
possible mais bref admettons que ce soit
possible un jour dans le futur bah c'est
juste une phange du squelette entier
c'est juste une clavicule de deux
squelettes donc on peut prendre
n'importe quel OS et répéter l'opération
n'importe quel autre OS et répéter
l'opération à l'inverse la clavicule qui
a été envoyée de sdiba dans l'espace
c'est aussi la clavicule qui avait été
en premier découverte par Matthew berger
le fils de li berger quand il avait 9
ans et donc maintenant cette clavicule
elle est passée de découverte par les
yeux d'un enfant et maintenant elle est
allée dans l'espace et c'est devenu le
premier fossile à aller dans l'espace le
premier fossile domininé et le premier
fossile tout court même je pense à aller
dans l'espace je veux dire maintenant
cette clavicule je veux dire elle a une
histoire et l'histoire je veux dire
cette histoire elle se reproduira pas
deux fois quoi c'est c'est c'est ouf
elle a une histoire de ouf cette
clavicule ça c'est irremplaçable et ce
genre de communication de ce genre
d'outil de communication je suis désolé
mais ça touche des gens qu'on ne
toucherait pas que la paléanthropologie
ne toucherait pas habituellement donc
soit so les amateurs de poésie soit les
amateurs d'astronomie mais ça a touché
des gens qui ne sont pas habituellement
touchés par la paléoanthropologie donc
je suis désolé mais non c'est c'est une
réussite c'est une réussite et à mon
avis à mon humble avis d'ailleurs
doisjejouter c'est c'est juste mon avis
à moi il vaut ce qu'il vaut à mon humble
avis le jeu envaller la chandelle il y a
pas vraiment pas et les questions
éthiques sont
rapidement sont rapidement
répondu à partir du moment où on décide
de mettre ses émotions de côté de pas
réagir à chaud de pas réagir
épidermiquement et surtout hein juste
parce que c'est li burger de ne de pas
réagir en disant si c'est li burger qui
l'a fait alors c'est de la merde parce
que ça je vous assure que une fois que
vous enlevez la couche de haine standard
pour liburger parce que li bururger
c'est une personnalité hein dans le le
milieu de la
paléoanthropologie c'est quelque chose
que j'avais déjà dit quand je parlais du
du documentaire Netflix mais que
peut-être j'ai pas insisté suffisamment
dessus mais liberger c'est une c'est une
personnalité dans le monde de la
paléoanthropologie et il est de bonne
àoi de de de de de voir tout ce que li
bururger fait comme étant l'incarnation
du mal c'est c'est c'est c'est un
phénomène psychosocial fascinant à
étudier quand quand on parle de de la du
milieu paléoanthropologique c'est la
haine engendrée par la seule mention du
nom le burger est colossal donc une fois
que vous en cette couche là de ce ce
cette petite mousse au sommet de votre
cappuccino là une fois que vous
l'enlevez cette couche de haine standard
pour les burger bah ce qui reste c'est
une analyse froide et détachée de de ce
qui s'est réellement produit et ce qui
s'est réellement produit ne diffère pas
fondamentalement de ce qu'on ferait pour
une exposition dans un musée
et la différence majeur étant qu'on a
que ils ont touché beaucoup plus de
monde que s'ils avaient fait ça pour une
expo dans un musée donc potentiellement
en réalité le c'est plutôt un winwin
c'est plutôt un win qu'un énorme fail
voilà donc ça je et je pense que c'est
important d'en parler en tout cas pour
moi c'est important d'en parler parce
que c'est il s'agit de mon institution
qui est qui est mise au ban là pour le
coup au ban des accusés c'est écrit
quelque part l'Université du VI wat r
voilà c'est mon institution ici dont il
s'agit c'est des collègues à moi là qui
ont eu des emmerde à la suite de ce
trucl donc pour moi c'est important d'en
parler d'exorciser ce démon en disant
mais non les gars réfléchissez 2
secondes arrêtez de réfléchir avec vos
émotions réfléchissez avec votre cerveau
et vous verrez qu'il s'est rien passé de
particulier en réalité et au contraire
ce qui s'est passé est très positif on
continue pour la première fois dans
palaleo NEWS j'ai une thématique vous
avez vu ça sur Internet et waouh what
the fuck c'est donc si vous avez
remarqué dans palaleo NEWS j'essaie
quand même d'avoir une organisation
assez thématique des articles que
j'aborde histoire que ça fasse un beau
flow avec des belles transitions et tout
ça euh mais là c'est la première fois je
crois alors je sais pas si c'est parce
que j'étais surcritique mais c'est
vraiment la première fois que j'ai une
catégorie vous avez vu ça sur internet
mais sérieusement c'est pas du tout ce
que vous croyez donc c'est c'est limite
du débunkage et pénitence à ce niveau-là
parce que il y a des trucs ça a été
what donc c'est vous avez vu ça sur
Internet et c'est pas du tout ce que
vous croyez on commence avec la limite
donc la la la limite Crétacé tertière
l'extinction des dinosaures n'a pas été
causé par le la météorite vous avez
certainement vu ça passer ce le mois
dernier sur Internet la la météorite n'a
pas été la cause de l'extinction des
dinosaures et en voici la preuve et la
preuve c'est cet article enfin c'est
cette communication qui a eu lieu
récemment renvoie à cet article là et
cet article là c'est pas du tout mais
alors pas du tout ça qu'il dit alors
c'est un article sorti dans Science donc
revue très prestigieuse de science je ne
remettrai pas la qualité de la science
en question mais mais cet article c'est
une modélisation des des environnements
anciens basés sur de la géologie mais
c'est une modélisation des niveaux de
dioxyde de carbone et de
soufre donc en fait si vous modélisez
les niveau de dioxyde de carbone et de
soufre à la limite entre le Crétacé et
le Paléogène bah vous modélisez quelque
chose qui a été exclusivement produit
par les volcans donc évidemment que vous
ne pouvez pas conclure sur autre chose
que l'intensité du
volcanisme c'est c'est un modèle un
modèle peut pas vous en dire plus c'est
un modèle c'est si même si vous
considérez qu'un modèle c'est une boîte
noire vous y rentrez des observations
vous en sortez des résultats hein on est
voilà on a même pas besoin d'expliquer
ce qu'il y a dans le modèle c'est juste
ça vous y rentrez des observations vous
ressortez des
résultats donc des modéisations bah si
vous y faites rentrer que que des
informations relatives au volcanisme le
modèle ne peut pas vous ressortir autre
chose que des informations relatives au
volcanisme et donc le modèle ne peut pas
tester l'hypothèse enin ne peut ne peut
rien tester qui soit relatif à
l'importance de la
météorite donc là vous vous cherchez des
trucs qui ont à voir avec le dioxyde de
carbone et le soufre qui sont des
produits du volcanisme bah évidemment
que le modèle va vous ressortir des
résultats qui qui vont vous dire oui le
volcanisme a produit du du dioxyde de
carbone et du soufre c'est pas une
critique pour eux hein pour l'article
c'est une critique pour les gens qui ont
communiqué à ce propol là en disant on a
la preuve que c'est le volcanisme et pas
la météorite qui a tué les dinosaures
ben non c'est pas du tout ça en fait au
départ donc il y a plusieurs millions il
y a
1,3 km C de basalt qui ont été produits
dans les traps du Décamp dont les
précédents modèles ont estimé que avait
émergé entre 4 et quasiment 10000
gigatonnes de carbone donc des milliards
de tonnes de carbone et 3 à 8 3000 à
8000 milliards de tonnes de soufre donc
on a des en gros on a un ordre de
grandeur qui est de l'ordre de de
milliers de gigatonnes de carbone et des
milliers de gigatonnes de soufre donc
leur modèle à eux suggère qu'en réalité
ça a été plutôt de l'ordre de dizaines
de milliers de gigatonnes de carbone et
de soufre c'est ça leur conclusion donc
32000 gigatonnes de carbone 15000
gigatonnes de soufre et donc
effectivement vous balancez 32000 g de
carbone et 15000 gigatonnes de soufre
dans l'atmosphère la biosphère elle va
manger mais jamais personne n dit le
contraire donc ce qu'il conclut hein
c'est que les volumes de gaz ont pu
possible sont sont cohérents avec une
activité
volcanique et donc on peut causer
l'extinction l'impact de chigzouou disIl
n'aura pas produit de telle quantité de
de carbone et de et de soufre mais enfin
ça personne n'en a jamais douté
c'est mais mais mais voilà c'est tout ce
que conclut l'article c'est un article à
propos du volcanisme le volcanisme à la
limite ce qu'on peut en conclure c'est
le volcanisme seul aurait-il pu
provoquer une extinction de masse la la
réponse est peut-être parce que ça fait
quand même une giga quantité de carbone
et de souffre relargué dans l'atmosphère
mais c'est tout c'est tout ce que dit
cet article il ne remet absolument pas
en question la chute de la météorite et
son influence sur l' action de masse
donc je ne sais pas d'où ils ont sorti
c'est d'où les médias ont sorti des des
titres pareils mais c'était ça ne ce
n'est pas ce que cet article dit on
continue dans la lignée du mais d'où
est-ce que ça sort avec Nature
Geoscience donc encore une fois revue
prestigieuse la branche géoscien de la
revue
Nature et vous avez certainement vu
passer dans les médias le la la
communication relative à cet articleci
communication dans les médias qui nous
disait les mammifères vont s'éteindre
avec la avec la formation de la
prochaine Pangée donc ce que dans cet
article ils appellent la pangeea Ultima
donc dans cet article ce qu'ils nous
disent c'est qu'ils ont fait des modèles
encore une fois des modèles
climatique pour voir si la formation de
la prochaine Pangée qui aura lieu selon
eux dans 250 millions d'années donc 250
millions d'années ça nous ramène à peu
près bah à la dernière extinction de
enfin à la plus grande extinction de
masse qui a eu lieu he il y a 252
millions d'années c'était la limite
permientrias donc c'est la plus grande
extinction de masse qui a eu lieu
c'était il y a 250 millions d'années et
donc ce que eux ils disent c'est que
dans 250 millions d'années il y aura une
nouvelle Pangée la Pangée ultime Pangéa
Ultima et en plus la formation de cette
Pangée bah va réduire la quantité de
côtes donc les les côtes vont
disparaître et quand les côtes
disparaissent vous avez un climat qui
devient beaucoup plus continental et
quand vous avez un climat beaucoup plus
continental il s'aridifie donc là c'est
qui est représenté très subtilement en
rouge pétant euh donc ça c'est une
conséquence attendue de la formation
d'une nouvelle Pangée un climat hyper
aride et donc c'est ce qu'ils confirment
dans leur discussion et ils disent les
mammifères d'aujourd'hui ne survivrai
pas à un tel climat et c'est là que j'ai
un problème c'est les prémisses de cet
article sont pas bons du tout c'estàdire
que il y a deux prémisses à cet article
le premier c'est que les mammifères
d'aujourd'hui he étant donné leur
biologie donc c'est tout ce tout ce
paragraphe là c'est que les mammifères
d'aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui today étant
donné leur biologie ne survivrai pas à
un
climat qui aura lieu dans 250 millions
d'années et en fait personne n'aurait
jamais remis ça en question et que si
vous prenez un mamifère d'aujourd'hui et
que vous le droppez dans 250 vous prenez
une machine à voyager dans le temps et
vous le lâchez dans 250 millions
d'années ce mammifère ne survivra pas
enfin vous pouvez prendre une population
entière de mammifères si vous le voulez
ces mammifères ne survivront pas et et
ça c'est juste la théorie de l'évolution
oui en effet c'est personne n'aurait
jamais remis en question le fait que oui
si tu prends un animal d'un temps donné
et que tu le droppes dans un autre temps
évidemment que il va pas survivre mais
ça jamais personne l'a remis en question
donc ça c'est le premier prémise oui le
premier prémise en fait c'est une
évidence c'est une tothologie c'est oui
si tu prends un mammifère d'aujourd'hui
il survivra pas ailleurs vous voyez
c'est il y a écrit tout today partout
partout les mammifères d'aujourd'hui
donc oui la biologie des mammifères
d'aujourd'hui ne leur permet pas de
survivre dans des environnements qui ne
sont pas les environnement d'aujourd'hui
ou relativement proche à ceux
d'aujourd'hui évidemment que dans 250
millions d'années l'environnement va
être très différent je rappelle il y a
252 millions d'années c'était la plus
grosse masse extinction de masse qui a
jamais qui a jamais eu lieu donc oui les
environnements change en 250 millions
d'années mais jamais personne aurait
remis en question ce prémis là donc
c'est un peu un fonçage de porte ouverte
niveau expert quoi c'està-dire qu'à ce
niveau-là c'est c'est du bombardement de
de yourourt quoi c'est la vous vous vous
pointez vous vous pointez dans un
camping avec un un B52 et vous bombardez
le camping alors que alors que toutes
leurs zipettes là elles étaient ouvertes
je dire pourquoi pourquoi donc jamais
personne s'est demandé ça et puis
l'autre prémise qui qui marche pas en
fait c'est le prémise que dans 250
millions d'années il y aura encore des
mammifères c'est un prémise c'est c'est
une très très lourde hypothèse he
l'hypothèse que dans 250 millions
d'années il y aura encore des mammifères
pour une raison très simple c'est que
les mammifères ils sont apparus il y a
150 millions d'années donc le le Clad
mamalia ici évoqué mamalia c'est un Clad
qui est apparu il y a 150 millions
d'années et vraiment en étalant très
très fort et très très loin la
définition du mot mamifère au mieux vous
remontrez il y a 200 millions d'années
au mieux la l'origine en réalité c'est
des mamaliamorphes donc des trucs qui
ressemblent à des mammifères et voilà
donc dire qu'il y a des mammifères à à
250 qu'il y aura encore des mammifères
dans 250 millions d'années c'est déjà
100 millions d'années de plus que ce à
quoi je m'attendrais quoi déjà dans 50
millions d'années enfin déjà on va
passer complètement sur la totale
imprévisibilité de l'évolution hein qui
qui qui fait que demain les les
mammifères peuvent s'éteindre hein c'est
pas c'est pas complètement exclu mais
bref c'est c'est déjà beaucoup plus que
ce à quoi on s'attend donc dire que dans
250 millions d'années il y aura pas de
mammifère bah c'est pareil c'est c'est
de l'enfonçage de de ht ouverte hein euh
c'est de l'enfonçage de camping et donc
la raison pour laquelle eux s'attendent
à ce que le il puisse encore y avoir des
mammifères dans 250 millions d'années
c'est que pour eux les mammifères sont
apparu il y A 310 millions d'années et
il cite une source qui est un article de
Timothy RA qui ne dit pas ça du tout
puisque je c'est un article que je
connais donc la source qu'il cite la
numéro 8 c'est un article de Timothy RW
un grand mamalogiste qui a pas du tout
dit
ça eux pour eux les mammifères sont
origin ont trouvé leur origine il y A
310 millions d'années 310 millions
d'années c'est c'est quasiment c'est
dimétrodon voyez le truc qui ressemblait
le plus fort à un mammifère il y A 310
millions d'années grosso merdo c'est
dimétrodon et donc on est très très très
très très très loin des mammifères donc
leur prémis est faux en fait le le
prémise que les mammifères ont déjà vécu
pendant 300 millions d'années donc ils
peuvent bien survivre encore pour 300
millions d'années il est faux donc je
comprends pas je je comprends pas
comment cette article en fait a passé
les tirs de barrage du peer review je
comprends pas comment ça se retrouve
dans Nature Geoscience parce que le
modèle est peut-être sexy hein et donc
j'imagine que les reviewers ont été des
des gens qui font de la modélisation
donc le le modèle il est peut-être sexy
et il fonctionne mais les les prémisses
en fait de la question scientifique sont
complètement sont complètement faux ou
des évidences en fait c'est c'est soit
du faux dans le cas de l'origine des
mammifères et soit c'est des évidences à
savoir que dans 250 millions d'années si
vous prenez un mammifère et sa biologie
actuelle il survivra pas oui je sais pas
c'est ça ça ça me c'est un mystère pour
moi cet article est un mystère pour moi
et peut-être que vous arriverez à
comprendre ce qu'ils ont essayé
d'accomplir mais moi j'ai arrive pas et
puis le le dernier truc qui m'a bon ça
m'a pas énervé là c'est c'est un article
publié dans Nature et donc c'est une
communication sur vous l'avez
certainement vu passer ça parce que ça a
vraiment beaucoup circulé on a retrouvé
le contenu stomacal d'un petit trilobit
qui nous vient de République
tchèqu si je me rappelle bien c'est ça
de du bassin de Prague en République
tchèque et donc il a un joli petit
contenu alors pas stomacal puisque ça
n'a pas d'estomac mais un contenu
intestinal devrais-je dire dans lequel
ils ont retrouvé bah du des morceaux de
d'quinodermes des morceaux de de petits
coquillages qui s'appelle des yolites et
des morceaux d'ostracot donc voilà c'est
la première fois en tout cas d'après eux
qu'on retrouve un trilobite avec son
contenu stomacal je enfin intestinal
euh je suis presque sûr qu'en cherchant
bien on doit en trouver d'autres mais il
ils ont certainement pas été aussi bien
étudiés voilà là ils ont quand même mis
les moyens il y a de a voilà il y a de
la belle imagerie 3D il y a une
reconstitution des éléments individuels
dans le dans le dans le le le l'intestin
de ce trilobit euh il y a une discussion
donc sur les les possibles raison
taphonomique pour laquelle tout ça a été
conservé le le truc en fait c'est juste
je comprends pas comment ça ça a buzé
autant enfin si c'est c'est certainement
les belles images tu vois mais je
comprends pas comment ça ça a buzé
autant parce que bah c'est qu'un seul
spécimen et du coup ça nous dit très
très peu de choses sur le comportement
général des trilobites en fait donc ce
trilobit là conclut-t-il était
probablement
un était probablement un charognard donc
voilà il il se baladait sur les fonds
marins et puis grignoait un peu tout ce
qui se passait mais c'est jamais de
toute façon quelle que soit la
conclusion qu'ils atteignent c'est une
conclusion qui n'est applicable qu'à une
seule espèce de trilobit il y aurait eu
une vingtaine de trilobit d'une
vingtaine d'espèces différentes qui
aurait permis d'avoir une image
fantastique de de la biologie des
trilobites de manière générale j'aurais
compris mais là avec juste un
spécimen je ouais alors comme je disais
j'ai j'ai je suis peut-être beaucoup
trop sélectif du fait que j'étais sur le
terrain et que j'avais pas le temps de
tout dire du coup j'ai peut-être t très
très très très très critique très
surcritique mais là j'avoue j'ai pas là
là j'ai pas accroché j'ai pas accroché
oui c'est très bien c'est j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'ils ont fait et ça mérite
le respect et ça méritait publication
mais est-ce que ça méritait une revue
prestigieuse et autant de communication
je ne sais pas mais il y a quand même
des choses qui m'ont fait plaisir hein
ne vous inquiétez pas je je suis pas
juste un rageux de l'Internet il y a des
choses qui m'ont fait beaucoup plaisir
publié dans scientific reports euh
encore une revue prestigieuse la
découverte des premières empreintes de
pied d'un Forus racidé les Forus racidé
ce sont les oiseaux de terreur hein le
le le Forus racos bref les les oiseaux
terreur les oiseaux géants
sud-américains carnivores et donc c'est
la première fois qu'on découvre des
empreintes de pied et ces empreintes de
pied et bien elles ont deux gros doigts
voyez deux gros doigts et le troisième
doigt il était tenu relevé avec vous
voyez ici une toute petite griffe au
bout alors c'est très bien représenté
par la dernière figure de l'article
voilà donc vous avez les empreinte en
orange et l'interprétation du pied
par-dessus et vous voyez c'est c'est
vous avez ces deux gros doigts et le
dernier doigt en fait qui était tenue
relevée avec une griffe recourbée euh
qui laissait juste la pointe et ça bah
ça fait fait penser à un vélociraptor et
surtout ça fait penser à un seriema les
serema ce sont ces ces oiseaux
sud-américains qui ont qui ont aussi
comme les vélociraptors qui gardent leur
leur doigt numéro 2 relevé avec une
grosse griffe recourbé donc ça c'est
super intéressant parce que ça démontre
finalement la façon dont se meuvaient
ces ces Forus racidés avec le doigt
numéro 2 généralement relevé pour
épargner justement le le bout de la
griffe et a conservé relativement
asserré et surtout ça montre que les
Forus racidés se déplaçaient un peu
comme des autruches c'est-àdire c'était
c'est il marchaent sur deux doigts les
les les autruches ont ça aussi ell ne
marche que sur deux doigts les les
autruches n'ont que deux doigts au pied
et pas trois et donc ils étaient très
très c'était probablement des prédateurs
très rapides euh en se basant en tout
cas sur la morphologie de de ces
empreinte là qui date euh si vous
regardez ce diagramme ici qui date
d'environ 7 millions d'années donc la
toute fin du on est à la toute fin du
miocè il y a plusieurs Forus racidés
possibles alors faut pas perdre de vue
et il le il le rappelle dans l'article
que en Amérique du Sud on a aussi les
nandou qui sont des gros oiseaux mais
les n en fait ces empreintes de pied
sont trop grandes pour appartenir à un
andou voilz ils estiment le poids
environ 55 kg étant donné la la taille
des empreintes on devait avoir un animal
d'à peu près 55 kg sachant que comme ils
le disent c'est probablement sous-estimé
euh mais les les nandous qui vivaient en
tout cas les prochespents des nandou qui
vivaient à l'époque miocen ne
dépassaient pas une vingtaine de kilo
donc il y a très peu de chance que ça a
été un un ou géant d'une espèce inconnue
et il y a plus de chance que ce soit un
des oiseau géants qu'on connaît déjà et
à savoir les fororus racidé donc il y a
plein de candidats possibles vous voyez
euh à la qui pourrait correspondre à ces
empreintes de pas eux ils vont pour une
espèce enfin ou une espèce qui s'appelle
maisembriornis insertus
ou en tout cas le genre
maisembriornis qui a été retrouvé voyez
qui est contemporain de ces empreintes
donc c'est quand même super cool parce
que les empreintes de pas encore une
fois c'est vous pouvez interpréter le
squelette autant que vous voulez en fait
vous n'aurez jamais réellement une image
de comment vraiment ces Forus racidés se
servaient de leur pied mais avec les
empreintes de pas bah vous avez un
enregistrement live en fait live dans le
sens où l'animal était vivant quand ces
empreintes ont été faites donc ça nous
montre réellement comment se tenaient
les fororus racidés au moins au moment
où ils ont fait cette empreinte et là en
plus ils ont même des pistes donc on les
voit courir quoi on les voit courir avec
leur peties griffes relevé c'est c'est
c'est c'est jurassiic Park en vrai quoi
c'est beau c'est beau les empreintes
c'est beau les empreintes ce sont les
vrais fossiles vivants ce sont les
fossiles qui ont été faits par des
animaux vivants on continue alors on
passe comportement on transitionne vers
le le cerveau c'est c'est une transition
un peu un peu chelou mais bon je fais ce
que je peux avec ce qu'on me donne le
cerveau des serpents étudié dans une
grande étude publiée dans Science
science
advances le cerveau des serpents moderne
étudié dans une grande étude et comparé
au cerveau des serpents fossiles vous
voyez c'est grosse grosse couverture
philogénétique he beaucoup beaucoup de
de spécimenses qui ont été étudiés inclu
des serpents fossilisés donc not
notamment les plus anciens serpents
connus he dinilesia et najash qui si je
ne me trompe pas date du début du
Crétacé et donc ce qu'ils ont remarqué
en fait en étudiant le cerveau des des
serpents fossiles c'est que les serpents
qui sont fouisseur les serpents qui
creusent ont un cervelet ici en rouge
qui est tout petit donc vous voyez ça
c'est des serpents normaux entre
guillemets et quand vous atteignez les
serpents qui sont soit des soit des
fouisseurs soit des fouisseurs
facultatifs donc ici en violet et en
orange bah là vous avez un cervelet qui
est tout rikiki et c'est exactement ça
qu'il trouve chez najash et chez
dinilisia ce qui suggère que najash et
dinilisia étaient possiblement des
serpent fouisseur et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que voyez c'est ce qui
est représenté ici he le dinilisia et
najash donc ce qui est représenté ici ce
sont c'est une reconstitution de leur
cerveau ancestral on va dire ancest
l'ancêtre des des serpents avec un tout
petit cervelet ce qui suggère en fait
que les serpents vivaient dans des
terriers au moins de façon
facultative et ça c'est important parce
que ça nous permet de comprendre en fait
comment les serpents ont perdu leurs
pattes à savoir qu'il y a beaucoup
d'espèces de lézards aujourd'hui qui
perdent leurs pattes d'une façon ou
d'une autre et généralement ce sont des
espèces qui sont soit aquatiques soit
semi-aquatiques plutôt soit qui sont
fuisseuses qui vivent sous TER terre et
il y a un grand débat pour essayer de
comprendre comment les serpents ont
perdu leurs pattes à savoir est-ce que
la perte des pattes était plutôt un
avantage pour se mouvoir dans l'eau ou
est-ce que la perte des pattes était
plutôt un avantage pour se mouvoir sous
terre euh et donc tous les serpents
seraient originaires soit d'un ancêtre
aquatique soit d'un ancêtre qui était
fouisseur et donc là euh preuve
cérébrale à l'appui apparemment les
ancêtres des serpents avaient plus de
chance d'être des fouisseurs que d'être
des des animaux euh des animaux
aquatiques quant à pourquoi est-ce qu'on
aurait besoin d'un petit cervelet pour
être fouisseur il ne l'explique pas donc
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
je ne peux pas vous dire en quoi avoir
un petit cervelet serait un avantage
pour les espèces fouisseuses j'imagine
que quand on est fouisseur on est
tellement restreint au niveau de sa de
sa mobilité que du coup le cervelet n'a
plus besoin d'être aussi gros mais bon
point d'interrogation point
d'interrogation et donc ce qui veut dire
aussi que les serpents qui ont un gros
cervelet aujourd'hui ont réévolué un
gros cervelet et ça c'est intéressant
aussi du CP on reste dans la belle
imagerie 3D avec un article publié dans
the anatomical record et qui nous
propose une nouvelle de nouvelles
simulations en fait sur les
tyrannosaures et leur puissance de
morsure alors comment qu'on reconstruit
la puissance d'un morsure d'un
tyrannosaur idé il y a plusieurs enfin
la tyrannosauroïde donc là on est
vraiment sur à l'échelle de tous les
tyrannosaures de manière générale depuis
Dong jusqu'à Tyrannosaurus rex quoi donc
depuis les plus anciens depuis les plus
anciens trucs qu'on appelle des des des
prochesparents des tyrannosaures
jusqu'au Tyrannosaurus rex donc c'est
pas que Tyrannosaurus rex en
l'occurrence et donc comment est-ce
qu'on étudie la puissance de morsure des
tyranosauroïdés bah déjà faut
reconstruire les insertions musculaires
euh des muscles de la mâchoire donc qui
sont ici représentés au niveau des
pterigoïdes et des fausses temporales
euh et après avoir reconstruit ça on
reconstruit on reconstitue en trois
dimensions la section de de ces muscles
puisque la puissance de morsure est
directement proportionnelle à la section
des muscles donc c'est ce que vous voyez
ici vous prenez une tranche de muscle et
cette tranche de muscle la la la surface
de cette tranche de muscle est
directement proportionnelle à la
puissance c'est quelque chose qu'on a
établi chez les animaux modernes il y a
une relation linéaire entre les deux et
on reconstitue donc la puissance de la
mâchoire et ensuite on fait des analyses
en élément finis c'est-à-dire des
simulations 3D en fait de morsures pour
voir comment le crâne réagit à
ces à la puissance en fait de ces
muscles qui tirent sur les EAU
évidemment ces muscles sont insérés sur
les EAU donc on on reconstitue la
puissance de ces muscles pour voir si le
crâne aussi est capable de supporter la
puissance
reconstituée de ces de ces muscles donc
on a une vraiment un double niveau de
vérification c'est-à-dire qu'on a cette
relation linéaire entre section des
muscles euh et le et la puissance des
muscles en question mais on a aussi
c'est cette géométrie en 3D du crâne
reconstitué sur ordinateur qui doit
résister la puissance musculaire en
question et donc avec ces deux niveaux
de vérification on peut reconstituer des
puissances de morsure et donc ce qu'ils
ont conclu grâce à ça bon ben c'est que
évidemment plus un crâne est petit plus
il a du mal à soutenir supporter les les
les puissances la puissance des morsures
ça c'est ce qu'on voit bien voyez les
plus les crânes sont gros vous voyez la
barre d'échelle hein la barre d'échelle
est à 20 cm donc là VO c'est un petit
crâne de de petit tyranosauroïde et là
c'est tyranosaurus et et
Tarbosaurus qui eux ont un crâne
gigantesque donc évidemment quand vous
avez les EAU plus épais quand vous avez
un gros crâne vous avez les EAU plus
épais vous avez vous supportez mieux des
puissances extraordinaires ça encore
c'est pas trop un problème ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant c'est que quand on regarde
les puissances de Mor morure telle que
reconstitué ici donc en Newton donc
tyranosaurus qui a une puissance de
morsure absolument
phénoménale comparé à tous ses petits
cousins jusqu'aux tyranosaurides les
plus basau donc les tyranosaurides les
plus basau ont des faibles puissances de
morsures comparé à Tyrannosaurus ça
aucun
problème ce qu'il y a d'intéressant
c'est des juvéniles de tyrannosaurin né
c'est-à-dire les tyrannosaures les les
enfin les les espèces de tyrannosaures
pour lesqueles on s'attend à ce qu'ils
ai des immenses puissances de morsures
donc vous avez tyranosaurus
Albertosaurus ça tout ça quoi donc ces
tyranosauris nés quand ils sont juvénils
en fait ils ont des puissances de
morsures qui s'approche en fait des
tyrannosaures basaux mais qui en moyenne
reste au-dessus de celle des
tyrannosaures basaux euh et notamment à
taille de crâne équivalente ce qui est
intéressant et qui disent dans cet
article c'est que à taille de crâne
équivalente en fait les tyrannosaures
Inés juvénil euh ont plus de puissance
dans les mâchoires que les
tyranosauroïdes
baso donc ça veut dire que en fait le
l'ontogénie ne récapitule pas la
phylogénie selon donc on n pas même si à
première vue on aurait les les juvéniles
qui auraient une puissance de morsure
équivalente à leurs ancêtres et puis
ensuite deviendrai ultra dérivé en
devenant adulte selon eux non il y a il
y a une architecture cranienne déjà à la
base dès dès le début en fait de
l'ontogénie des tyranosaurinés dès leur
tout premier pas en tant que que petit
poussin un tyrannosaure ces
tyrannosaurinés en fait dès qu'ils
sortent de l'œuf ils ont déjà une
architecture crânienne qui les rend
immément puissant comparé à leurs
ancêtres et ça c'est plutôt intéressant
parce que du coup c'est c'est c'est ça
ça illustre quand même assez bien que
les tyranosauridé en fait ça illustre
assez bien que l'architecture crânienne
était vraiment quelque chose de
profondément codé dans la génétiqu des
tyrannosaures quoi donc c'est c'est
quand même assez intéressant à constater
et ici donc vous avez bah une belle
phylogénie des tyranosauroïdes depuis
les plus anciens comme procératosaurus
et Dilong par exemple jusqu'à
tyranosaurus et Tarbosaurus et comment
ils résistent en fait aux pressions de
de leur propre mâchoire quoi et donc ça
devient de plus en plus bleu et de plus
en plus safe en fait au fur à mesure que
vous grimpez dans la phylogénie donc des
puissances musculaires qui augmente de
façon
incroyable comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ce graphe des puissances musculaires qui
au fur et à mesure de la phylogénie
augmente de façon incroyable mais qui du
coup s'accompagne d'une architecture
crânienne qui rend qui compense pour
cette puissance qui rend cette qui
absorbe cette puissance de mieux en
mieux donc c'est la la grosse tendance
évolutive que vous pouvez voir ici chez
les tyrannosaur chez les
tyrannosauroïdes puis au jusqu'au
tyrannosauriné jusqu'au genre
Tyrannosaurus qui est le point culminant
de cette tendance où on a justement un
animal qui est
ostéophage en tout cas c'est ce qui
c'est ce qu'ils disent à la fin leur
conclusion c'est que Tyrannosaurus était
un prédateur ostéophage ça donc
prédateur pas charognard était un
prédateur ostéophage donc c'est un
prédateur qui défoncer ses proies en
leur broyant les os en leur broyant les
os avec ses mâchoires mais tout ça
aurait commencé avec des petits débuts
un peu modestes des animaux comme
Dong qui devaient se nourrir de petites
proies teles que des mammifères des
reptiles et Cera parce que leur mâchoire
justement était très faible ceci étant
dit il y a eu cette adaptation clé dès
le démarrage de de la lignée des
tyranosauroïde qui a été la fusion des
EOS Nao donc la fusion des os qui se
trouve juste ici au sommet de la
mâchoire et donc la pression de la de la
mâchoire ici durant la morsure se
disperse vers le haut et va vers les
zones Azo c'est ce qu'on voit très bien
par exemple ici chez daspletosaurus
voyez la pression exercée au niveau de
la mâchoire monte ici dans la région
nasale et donc c'est ici qu'il va y
avoir de la pression et les premiers
tyrannosauroïdes en fait avaient déjà
les zonazo fusionné certains formant
même des crêtes et ça en fait ça a
possiblement été un
caractère un critère finalement une
préadaptation comme certains l'appellent
ça a possiblement été une préadaptation
à cette morsure formidable qui a fini
par évoluer chez les tyranosauriné donc
à la base cette fusion des zonesazo elle
avait peut-être juste une fonction de de
démonstration voyez de de parade sexuel
euh la fusion des zonesazo permettant la
formation de ces belles crêtes ou de
cette rugosité qu'on voit chez les tout
premiers
tyranosauroïdes mais elle aurait été
ensuite récupérée par les
tyranosauriidés et les tyrannosauri né
plus dérivé
euh comme une stratégie de renforcement
finalement de des mâchoires et ça c'est
vachement intéressant euh à constater
parce que parce que parce que ça répond
à pas mal de questions sur comment les
tyrannosaures ont développé finalement
l'une des mâchoires les plus puissantes
du règne animal et c'est vachement cool
et il y a un de mes étudiants au
générique j'ai oublié de préciser Adam
Adam qui est aussi un Paléo artiste et
je pense que enfin il m'a dit c'est pas
je pense il m'a dit c'est Lui qui a créé
les modèles 3D donc Adam qui a créé les
modèles 3D pour cette étude du coup a
participé et se trouve générique de cet
article donc félicitations Adam et on
termine ce paléon news avec une une
curiosité plus que plus qu'une que
quelque chose de très très pointu mais
c'est une curiosité donc c'est une
analyse de la paléobiology database donc
de la base de données paléobiologique si
vous connaissez c'est un site
extraordinaire c'est un site internet
extraordinaire donc si vous connaissez
pas paléobiologie database c'est un site
qui recense géographiquement toutes les
découvertes paléontologiques pendant
tout le fanerosoï c'està-dire prend
toute la période où on trouve à bal de
fossil c'est une immense entreprise euh
enfin c'est un immense effort plutôt
devrais-je dire c'est pas une entreprise
dans le sens où ils font de l'argent
avec ça mais c'est un immense effort qui
a été produit pour générer cette base de
données elle est toujours en
construction à l'heure où on parle parce
que évidemment c'est que des étudiants
et des volontaires qui qui rentrent un
par un les articles et les fossiles des
collections et cetera et cetera donc
c'est c'est pas encore fini hein comme
comme base de données mais maintenant
ils ont atteint un niveau où quand même
depuis plus de 15 ans maintenant qu'
travaillent là-dessus ils arrivent à
faire des analyses assez complètes de du
jeu de données la base de données et
notamment dans cet article ben il nous
propose une cartographie en fait des
zones qu'il reste à explorer et il
conclut sans trop de surprise que
l'Amérique et l'Europe faut arrêter on
connaît vachement bien ce qui s'y passe
et par contre l'Amérique du Sud et
l'Afrique serait peut-être temps de se
sortir les doigts du cul d'autant qu'en
Amérique du Sud et en Afrique ce qui ce
qu' le pointe du doigt ici c'est que on
a surtout des terrains qui sont
continentaux donc si on veut en savoir
plus
sur l'évolution des vertèbrés terrestres
l'évolution des tétrapodes les
dinosaures par exemple les ominidé par
exemple bah c'est dans ces coins là où
il faudrait bon les hominid en Amérique
du Sud j'avoue c'est pas top mais euh
enfin au-delà de 7000 ans vous allez pas
en trouver beaucoup hein allez 15000 ans
juste pour être pour être bien sûr mais
voilà c'est surtout des terrains
continentaux donc si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur les dinosaures l'origine
des mammifères l'origine des des
vertébrés de manière générale il
faudrait se sortir les doigts du cul
pour aller explorer ces régions là donc
voilà si jamais vous vous me posiez la
question si jamais vous vous posiez la
question est-ce qu'il reste encore des
choses à découvrir c'est une question
que j'aborde très souvent hein mais si
vous vous posiez la question reste-t-il
encore des choses à découvrir bah la
raison pour laquelle vous vous posez
cette question c'est parce que vous êtes
un habitant d'un pays développé d'un
pays de de l'Occident et que on a trop
échantillonné c'est eux qui utilisent
l'expression ils utilisent oversampling
dans cet article donc on a trop
échantillonné dans nos régions donc on a
vraiment cette impression d'une
complétude de de nos connaissances qui
qui est fausse parce qu'en réalité il y
a des régions qui sont sous-
échantillonnées notamment l'Afrique et
l'Amérique du Sud alors c'est dû bah
c'est dû déjà au fait qu'il y a pas il y
a pas beaucoup de paléontologie locale
hein il y a pas du il y a pas de il y a
pas beaucoup de grandes universités qui
produisent des paléontologues locaux
c'est dû au fait aussi souvent à
l'accessibilité alors que ce soit à
cause des jungles qui évidemment empêche
l'accès au à la rocheem ou que ce soit
les situations politiques aussi hein qui
qui rendent les l'accès au si vous
voulez ils ont d'autres priorités quoi
hein voilà la situation politique
faisant ils ont ils ont d'autres
priorités que d'envoyer des gugus dans
la forêt pour aller chercher des
fossiles donc bref vous avez cette on a
cette impression en fait de très trop
bien connaître le registre fossile
uniquement parce que bah on vient de
pays qui ont un échantillonnage très
très très très très très très complet
mais il y a plein de pays où c'est pas
le cas et du coup c'est ils sont pointés
du doigt très très bien je trouve par ce
par cette carte ici donc là vous avez la
carte géologique en gros et là vous avez
la carte chaque point représentant un un
échantillon enregistré dans la
paléobiology database et donc on voit
ces immenses zones de
vide à travers la carte donc voilà si
vous si vous vous posiez la question de
savoir où qu'il faut aller chercher des
fossiles c'est cet article là qu'il faut
consulter voilà c'était palaleo news je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'ancien et je vous dis à très
[Musique]
bientôt